chants of religious fervor fill the air
at a mosque in central Somali this men
are followers of Sufism or mystical
Islam for the first 20 years of Somalia
civil war Sufis completely avoided the
conflict but a decade ago they were
forced to pick up arms and join the
fight against al-shabaab their shrines
were being destroyed their leaders were
being killed their beliefs were under
withering attack where coca leaf reign
in air cotton it's the tourists who
forced us to take up arms when we saw
foreign fighters and foreign ideology
invading our country and wishing to wipe
out all our efforts to spread a more
tolerant and rational Islam that is when
we decided to defend ourselves in our
belief for 10 years the Sufi fighters
Photoshop urban ministry take the group
strongholds in the windswept plains of
central Somalia the Sufi fighters are
perhaps the only local group to go up
against al-shabaab fighters and win the
group's leadership say this is due to
strong support from local communities
which explains how they were able to
move from a bunch of men who had never
squeezed the trigger to a proper
fighting force in a surprise move two
months ago the group decided to have
their fighters integrated into Somalia's
national army former Sufi fighters were
disarmed hard their biometrics taken and
were included into the ranks of the
government forces or Alyson noël Itamar
in I am Camilla
we agreed to have our fighters
integrated into the federal forces to
give them an opportunity to replicate
what they did in these parts and help
save the entire country from al-shabaab
Abdul Mohammed Sabri is Somalia's
interior minister he says the addition
of Sufi fighters into the national
forces has been a huge boon for the
government
well after Hamad wobble on Haram it was
inevitable to integrate the Sufi
fighters into the national forces we
cannot claim to have a government when
entities outside it continue to have
their own forces nonetheless we are
happy to have such an effective armed
group bolstering our ranks the Sufis say
their fight with Al Shabaab is far from
over
they say the conflict is Somalia is an
ideological one and they say they will
now use their tolerant brand of Islam to
turn the tide against al-shabaab
Mohammed I do al Jazeera do some Arab in
central Somali